تتعرض هذه البرية البكر
للتهديد ، حيث
يمكن أن تؤدي الكارثة البيئية هنا إلى نهاية العالم البشرية
لأن محبوسين في الغابة عبارة عن
خزانات لعدوى قاتلة
ربما تكون بعضها أكثر خطورة
مما رأيناه من قبل
في الجندي على بعد 400 ميل من نهر
جمهورية الكونغو الديمقراطية.
أصيب العاصمة بسبب تفشي
فيروس الإيبولا القاتل مؤخرًا ،
فقد قتل ثلاثة من كل 11 مريضًا
هنا ، لكن الأطباء يخشون من أنهم عثروا
على فيروس جديد قد لا يكون
هناك علاج
أو علاج ، وعلينا إجراء المزيد من الفحوصات
لمعرفة ذلك.  ما الذي يحدث ، لذلك
أخبرني الأطباء للتو أن أحد
مخاوفهم الفورية
هو أنهم يحصلون على حالات تظهر الآن
أعراضًا مشابهة للإيبولا ولكن
عندما يختبرونها في المختبر
هنا ،
فإنهم يظهرون بشكل سلبي أن هذا المريض
مصاب بالإيبولا  الأعراض
لكنها كانت سلبية. إنها واحدة من
ضحيتين هنا
ربما تقاومان مرضًا لم
أواجهه قبل أن
أسأل عن ذلك  ctor إذا كان قلقًا
بشأن ظهور أمراض جديدة ،
نعم بالفعل يجب أن تخشى أن يكون سبب ظهور مرض
الإيبولا غير معروف في مرض معروف ،
ثم بعد الاختبار تبين أنه علاج
فيروسي
ولقاح للإيبولا
يعني الآن أنه في كثير من الأحيان
المزيد من المرضى القاتلين لا يزالون على قيد الحياة ، لكن الطب
لن يواكب الأمراض الجديدة
الناشئة من البرية ، حيث
نجا المرضى هنا ،
لكن اختبارات الأمراض المعروفة كانت كلها
سلبية ،
لذا لا يزال مرضها لغزًا
يخشى الأطباء من أن المزيد من الأمراض الحيوانية المنشأ
مثل
فيروس إيبولا ومرض الإيدز وفيروس نقص المناعة البشرية
سيظهر covid19 ويجعل تلك القفزة من
الحيوانات إلى البشر.
كانوا في بؤرة
المعركة الأخيرة ضد الإيبولا
التي أودت بحياة 55 شخصًا في المقاطعة
هنا في بندقة التي
يقاتلون معها  التفشي المحلي الخامس
لفيروس الإيبولا الذي كان
في الحادي عشر
هنا في الكونغو ، فهم يسيطرون
عليه كما يعتقدون ،
لكنهم قلقون أيضًا بشأن العثور على
فيروسات غير معروفة ظهرت
من الغابة
تمامًا مثل الإيبولا التي يعاني منها العلماء
هنا  أموال محدودة لكنهم يعرفون أن
عملهم ضروري
لحماية بلدهم
وبقية البشرية
إذا لم يكن لدينا كل هذا في مكانه ،
يمكنك تخيل سيناريو تسعة رجال حيث
يكون لديك وباء واسع النطاق مع العديد من
الحالات التي
تؤدي إلى  معدل الوفيات والمراضة الهائلة
تم اكتشاف أكثر من مائة فيروس جديد
في جمهورية الكونغو الديمقراطية على مدار عقد من الزمن
بما في ذلك
العديد من فيروسات كورونا في الخفافيش ،
لذا فإن الخفافيش التي تحصل على الخفافيش المتعقبة
مرتبطة بالعديد من الأمراض الحيوانية المنشأ التي تغطيها بشكل خاص
19 والإيبولا
التي سنضعها فيها  حقيبة الالتقاط ،
يجب أن تكون حذرًا حقًا
أو تناقش مع علماء الفيروسات الذين أخبرونا
أنه في حين أنهم لم يعثروا على
فيروس الإيبولا نفسه بداخلهم ، فقد
وجدوا الأجسام المضادة لذلك
تعتبر نوعا خافرا نوعا ما
نظام إنذار مبكر
للبشرية ، يمكن أن تثبت
الوباء أن الوباء قاتل أو أسوأ من
ذلك ، لذلك يمكن أن تنتقل العدوى من
مضيف غير معروف
إلى الخفافيش إلى الدجاج إلى الأطفال ، حيث
يتم مسح حوالي 80 من الخفافيش للاختبار
السري والإيبولا
ثم  يتم إرسال العينات إلى
كينشاسا لإجراء مزيد من التحقيقات ،
حيث يعيش معظمهم على قيد الحياة
ويعودون إلى البرية
، وقد تضاعف عدد سكان الكونغو تقريبًا
خلال عقدين من الزمن إلى حوالي 90
مليونًا ،
مما يضع الغابة تحت الضغط
ويغلق الفجوة بين
الناس والأمراض الجديدة التي  يمكن أن يقتلهم ،
فإن حجم تدمير
الغابات المطيرة هنا في الكونغو لم يصل بعد
إلى النطاق الذي رأيناه في
الأمازون ، وكان الكثير منه
نتيجة للمزارعين المحليين الذين يزيلون الأرض ثم
يزرعونها من أجل  سنوات قليلة تكمن المشكلة في
أن هذا يتسبب في
تجزئة الغابات المطيرة
مما يؤدي إلى زيادة المساحة السطحية بين
الغابة والبشرية ، لذلك هذا هو
أستاذ الغابة جي مويمبي
وهو خبير في  في الأمراض الناشئة ، كان يتتبعها
منذ أن اكتشف الإيبولا في عام
1976 والآن لديه تحذير لنا جميعًا ، لذا
فقد
أصبح تفشيًا ، هل تخشى أن يكون هناك
المزيد من الأمراض الناشئة القادمة من
الغابة شيء ربما
ينتشر مثل  كوفيد ولكنه يقتل مثل الإيبولا ،
نحن الآن في عالم
ستظهر فيه مسببات الأمراض الجديدة
التي ستشكل تهديدًا للبشرية
، وكما تعلم فإن معظم هذه الأمراض
تظهر من
إفريقيا وهذا في الكونغو هو كيف تسافر الفيروسات في
الغالب
في نهر الكونغو.  شريان عظيم
يمنح الحياة للأمة بأكملها ولكنه
أيضًا الطريق الذي يتم من خلاله
تصدير نتائج إزالة الغابات
مثل هذه القرود المدخنة التي يتم بيعها للطعام
أنا أقوم بتصوير متخفٍ لأن التجار هنا
في الأنواع المحمية يخشون التعرض
آدامز هو دليلي
مرة واحدة طعام الكفاف الآن  لحوم الطرائد هي
سلعة فاخرة دولية قيل لي إنه لا توجد مشكلة هناك
وكالة لهذا
النوع المحمي الذي يرأسه القرود
و  يجب قطع rms لإخفائها
بلحوم الظباء ، لقد
شهدنا تدفق
المغتربين بشكل رئيسي من جنوب
شرق شرق
آسيا والذين يطالبون بأكل
أنواع معينة من اللحوم مثل السلاحف والثعابين
الرئيسيات وتقدر الأمم المتحدة أن حوالي
خمسة ملايين طن من اللحوم
البرية  يتم حصادها كل عام من حوض الكونغو ،
ولكن المصدر الأكثر فاعلية للفيروسات
هو الحيوانات الحية
التي تحمل الفيروسات ويمكن أن تصيبها
عندما يتم ذبحها أو مداعبتها في
حدائق الحيوان الخاصة ، تعد
الحيوانات الحية ولحوم الطرائد جزءًا من
تجارة عالمية بمليارات الدولارات
وهي  سبب وأعراض
كارثة بيئية
[موسيقى]
جنبًا إلى جنب مع قطع الأشجار
والضغط الصناعي يمكن إطلاق أعداد لا حصر لها من الإصابات المحتملة
والآن يبدو الأمر كما لو أن
الطبيعة
قد وجدت طريقة لحماية نفسها ،
حيث يعد الحبس في مستودع الأسلحة في
الغابة سلاحًا ضد  التهديد الأكثر فتكًا بالبشرية على كوكب الأرض
، وإذا كان الأمر كذلك ، فإن هذا القصر المهجور
لدكتاتور ميت منذ زمن طويل
ليس من بقايا الماضي
[موسيقى]
إنه يمثل  أيون لما يبدو عليه الكوكب
عندما تقاومك الأرض الأم